The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: All right.
I should probably start.
Last time, we were talking
about the honeycombs
and doing some modeling
of the mechanical behavior
and we started off talking
about the in plane behavior.
We're talking about loading
it in this direction
or that direction there.
And we talked about
the elastic modulus.
I think I derived
a Young's modulus
for the one direction, a
Poisson's ratio for loading
in the one direction.
And then we started talking
about the stress plateau
and we went over the
elastic buckling stress,
for one of these elastomeric
honeycombs like this.
And we went through the plastic
collapse stress, for, say,
a metal honeycomb
that would yield.
And I think I started talking
about a brittle honeycomb and
brittle crushing.
The idea with a
brittle honeycomb--
like a ceramic honeycomb-- is it
could fail in a brittle manner.
And the failure is going to
be controlled by the cell wall
in bending.
And when that bending stress
reaches the modulus of rupture,
or the bending strength
of the material,
then you get wall fracture.
I think that's where we
left it last time, right?
I had written down something
about cell wall fracture.
Now, I wanted to do
the little derivation.
Here's our little
schematic up here.
Here's the honeycomb.
You've loaded it with sigma
1 here to such an extent
that one of these cell walls has
reached the modulus of rupture
and has broken.
And this is the little free
body diagram that corresponds.
I'm going to go through
sigma 1 for loading
in the one direction.
This is the same thing for
loading in the two direction.
And the result for
that's in the book.
OK.
If I have loading in
the one direction,
I can relate that
horizontal force p
to the stress in
the one direction.
The little p is equal to sigma 1
times h plus sin theta times b.
And remember, b's the
depth into the page.
And I'm going to define sigma
fs as the modulus of rupture
of the cell wall material.
It's the bending strength
And we're going to say that we
get fracture of that bent wall
when the applied moment is
equal to the fracture moment.
From the plastic collapse
stress from last time,
we had the applied moment
was equal to p times l
sin theta over 2.
That was just using
static equilibrium,
looking at that free
body diagram of the beam.
And if I write p, in
terms of sigma 1 up here,
I can just write that like
this sigma 1 times h plus l
sin theta times b.
And then I've got this
other term of l sin theta
and we divide that
whole thing by 2.
That's the applied moment.
And we're going to
get fracture when
we reach the fracture moment.
I'm going to call that mf--
the moment at fracture.
Last time, we figured
out a plastic moment
to form a plastic hinge.
And this is an analogous thing.
But in this case,
remember, if we have a beam
and we have the stress profile
through the cross section
of the beam, it's going to
look something like that.
So for our beam, that's going
to be the thickness of the beam
there.
So if it's linear elastic,
we get the maximum stress
at the top and the bottom.
And the neutral axis
is here in the middle.
There's no stress there.
This is the normal
stress distribution here.
And as we increase the stress
for a brittle material that's
going to be linear
elastic till fracture,
this is going to
stay linear like this
until we reach this modulus
of rupture stress here.
When we reach that
stress, then we're
going to get
fracture of the beam.
And we can say that there's some
moment associated with that.
I could say that this
stress block here
is equivalent to some
concentrated force
and this stress block
down here is also
equivalent to the-- it's
going to the same magnitude,
but the opposite
direction force.
And I can get the
fracture moment
by figuring out how
big those forces are
and multiplying by this moment
arm between the two forces.
OK?
The magnitude of
those forces is just
going to be the volume,
essentially, of this stress
block here.
Imagine there's stresses there.
It's a triangle,
so the area of it's
going to be a half times t
over 2 times of sigma fs.
And it's going to
go b into the page.
So if you think of the force--
if this was the stress--
if that stress was
constant, it would just
be sigma fs times b times t.
But it's not constant.
It's a linear relationship.
So I'm taking the
area of that triangle.
That's the force.
And then I want to multiply
that times the moment arm.
And the moment arm between
those two forces-- each
of these forces acts through
the centroid of the area.
The centroid of the area is not
in the middle for a triangle,
and that total distance is
2/3 of the thickness, t.
OK?
That's the moment
arm that you get
by figuring out where the
centroid of these areas are.
I multiply that times 2/3
t and one of the 2's is
going to cancel.
I can rewrite that and sigma fs
times b times t squared over 6.
OK?
I think, last time
when we talked
about the plastic moment,
we did a similar calculation
and it worked out to
sigma y bt squared over 4.
So now this is sigma fs,
the modulus of rupture,
times bt squred over 6.
The 6 is just slightly
different because we've
got a triangle here instead
of a square shape like we
had before.
And now I can get the
brittle crushing strength
and compression by just
equating that applied moment
to this fracture moment.
And if you do that,
the result you get
is this plateau stress
for brittle crushing
and compression.
In the one direction,
it's sigma fs--
the modulus of rupture of
the cell wall-- times t
over l squared.
And then divided by
a geometrical factor.
And her regular
hexagons, it works out
to 4/9 of the modulus of
rupture times t over l squared.
OK?
Are we good?
We've got the in plane
compressive properties now.
We've got the elastic
moduli and we've
got the three plateau stresses
that correspond to the three
mechanisms-- to the elastic
buckling failure mechanism,
the plastic yielding mechanism,
and then the fracture mechanism
for brittle crushing.
OK?
If you think of the
stress-strain curve
of these materials
in compression,
the stress strain curves all
look something like that.
And now we've
figured out equations
that give us the modulus here
and our collapse stress there.
OK?
So we can describe that
stress-strain curve.
All right.
That's compression.
And the next thing I wanted
to talk about is tension.
And if we think about
the tensile behavior,
the elastic moduli are
going to be just the same.
So the moduli are the same
in tension and compression.
And then, if we think
about the stress plateau,
we don't really have
a stress plateau
for an elastomeric
material because there's
no elastic buckling.
If you pull it in
tension, you're
not going to get
buckling in tension.
You only get buckling
if it's in compression.
If you have a material
that yields like a metal,
you can get a plastic collapse
stress and a plastic plateau.
And that's very similar in
tension and compression.
There's a very small
geometrical difference,
but you can,
essentially, ignore it.
If you're loading the
material in compression--
and imagine this was a metal--
if you load it in compression,
the cell walls are getting
a little further apart when
I compress it.
And if you're
loading in tension,
like this, the cell walls
are getting a little closer
together.
So there's a small
geometrical difference.
But if we ignore
that, we can say
that the plateau stress
for plastic behavior
is about the same in
tension and compression.
And so really, the only
property that's left
is to look at a
brittle honeycomb.
And for a brittle honeycomb,
you can have fast fracture
and we can calculate
a fracture toughness.
So this next slide describes the
fracture toughness calculation
that we're going to do.
Here's our honeycomb.
I'm going to load it in
the sigma 1 direction here.
I've turned the
honeycomb 90 degrees,
so this is still sigma 1.
And imagine now that
we've got a crack here.
And I'm going to
consider a situation
where the crack is very large,
relative to the cell size.
So it's not a crack
in the cell walls.
It's a crack that goes
through multiple cells.
I'm going to assume
the crack is large,
relative to the cell size.
I'm going to assume that the
bending is the main deformation
mode.
And what I'm going to do is
look at-- if I have my crack tip
here, I'm going to
look at this cell wall
a just ahead of the crack tip.
And I'm going to say,
that cell wall is bent.
And I'm going to
figure out something
about the stress
in that cell wall
and look at when that fails.
And I'm going to assume
that the cell wall has
a constant modulus of rupture.
So the cell wall has
a constant strength.
You can imagine the
cell wall could have
little tiny cracks in it, too.
And if a cell wall
has a bigger crack,
it's going to fail
at a lower stress.
But let's imagine that the cell
walls are all the same strength
and they all have a
constant modulus of rupture.
Let me write some of this down.
In tension, the elastic
moduli are going to the same
as in compression.
There's no elastic
buckling in tension,
so that's not going to happen.
The plastic plateau
stress in tension
is going to be very similar
to that in compression.
As I mentioned, there's a
small geometrical difference,
but we're going to ignore that.
And then, if we had
a brittle honeycomb,
like one of those ceramic
honeycombs I showed you,
then we can have fast fracture.
What we want to calculate
is the fracture toughness.
And I'm going to make
a few assumptions here.
I'm going to assume that
the crack length is large
compared to the cell size.
And if I do that,
I can say that I'm
going to use the
continuum assumption.
Hello.
We'll come back to that.
I'm going to say that axial
forces can be neglected.
We're just going to
look at bending forces.
And I'm also going to assume
that the modulus of rupture
is constant for the cell wall.
First, let's just think
again about the continuum.
Imagine we just had a solid and
we have a plate of the solid
and it's loaded in tension
with some remote stress--
some far away stress-- sigma 1.
And the plate has a crack
of length 2c perpendicular
to that normal stress.
And we're going to look at
the stress-- local stress
at the crack tip-- some distance
r ahead of the crack tip there.
In fracture mechanics,
it's been worked out what
that local stress field is.
And it depends on
the crack length,
and then how far ahead
of the crack tip you are.
So you can say that if you've
got a crack length of 2c
in a linear elastic
solid, and the crack is
normal to a remote
tensile stress-- which
I'm going to call sigma
1-- then that crack
is going to create a local
stress field at the crack tip.
And we're going to use this
equation for the local stress
field.
The local stress field is
equal to the far away field
divided by-- or multiplied
by the square root of pi c
and divided by the
square root of 2 pi r.
So there's a stress
singularity at the crack tip.
And then the local stress
decays as you move away
from the crack tip.
AUDIENCE: And what is r?
LORNA GIBSON: r is the
distance from the crack tip.
So if that's the tip
of my crack there,
then r is my distance out.
OK.
In the honeycomb wall, if
we look at the crack here,
and then we look
at that cell wall a
that's just ahead of the crack
tip, that cell wall is bent.
So in the honeycomb, we're going
to be looking at the bent cell
wall.
And that wall is going to fail
when the applied moment equals
the fracture moment.
If we look at wall
a, we could say
that the applied moment is
going to be proportional to p
times l.
Getting ahead of myself there.
I'm going to do
this-- because it's
hard to say exactly where the
crack tip is because there's
a void there.
I'm going to use that
argument here where
I make everything proportional.
The moment's going to be
proportional to p times l
on wall a.
And the fracture stress is going
to be proportional to sigma fs
times bt squared.
Last time, we said it was
sigma fs bt squared over 6.
It's the same thing.
I'm just dropping the 6 out.
And then I can also say
that this applied moment,
if it goes as pl--
p is just going
to be my local stress times lb.
And then I multiply times l.
So if you think of
just thinking about--
if you got a load p
on this member here,
l, there's going to be
some local stress there.
And p is just going to be that
local stress times the cell
wall length times the
width into the page.
And then, that local
stress, sigma l,
I can replace with that
equation over there.
So that local stress is going
to go as sigma 1 times the root
of c over the root of r.
And I'm going to say the
distance ahead of the crack tip
goes as l.
Instead of having r,
I'm going to say it's l.
It's not necessarily
exactly l, but it's
going to be some fraction of l.
That's my local stress there.
And then I've got an
l squared times b.
And if I set that equal
to the fracture moment,
that's going to be proportional
to sigma fs bt squared.
Are we good here?
You have to think
of the crack tip.
And there's some local stress
field ahead of the crack tip.
And we're saying
that the load p is
equal to that local stress times
a cell length times the depth
into the board.
And then multiply it
times l to get the moment.
And then I replace
that local stress
with this standard equation for
the remote stress and the crack
length and the distance
ahead of the crank tip.
So here, the b's are
going to cancel out.
And now I can solve for a
fracture stress in the one
direction.
And that's going
to-- well, let me
get proportional-- that's going
to be proportional to sigma fs.
Then there's going to
be a t over l squared.
And then, this is going to
go as the square root of l
over c like that.
And now, if I want to
get a fracture toughness,
the fracture toughness
is just the strength
times the square root of pi
times the half crack length c.
So here, my fracture toughness
is just that strength
times the root of pi c.
So I can say that's equal to a
constant times sigma fs times t
over l squared.
And now, times the
square root of l.
These root of c's
have canceled out.
So that's my equation for
the fracture toughness.
And one of the
interesting things
here is that the
fracture toughness
depends on the cell size.
This is the first
property that we've
derived an equation for where
it depends on the cell size.
OK.
And here, c's just
going to be a constant.
All right.
Now we've got a set of
equations that describe
the in plane properties.
We've got equations
that describe
the linear elastic
moduli in the plane.
We've got three equations that
describe the compressive stress
for elastic buckling failure,
for plastic yielding failure,
and for a brittle
crushing failure.
And we've got an equation
for the fracture toughness,
as well.
OK?
We've got a description
of the in plane behavior
of these hexagonal honeycombs.
The next thing I wanted to
do was talk a little bit
about in plane behavior, but
for a different cell shape--
for triangular honeycombs.
Because they deform by
a different mechanism.
And they can be used to
represent the lattice materials
that we looked at earlier, too.
If we have a
triangular honeycomb
with triangular cells,
triangulated cells
behave like a truss.
And you can analyze trusses by
just saying that the joints are
pin jointed.
There's no moments at
the end of the joints
or end of the members.
And the forces are
all axial and so
the behavior's a
little bit different.
I wanted to show you how these
triangular honeycombs work,
too.
I can scoot this up.
Imagine that you've
got a honeycomb that's
an array of triangular
cells like this.
And say we're applying some bulk
stress sigma to it, like that.
And say it's got a
depth b into the page.
When we have a triangulated
structure like this,
it behaves like a truss.
And we can analyze it as
being a pin-jointed structure.
There's no moments at the joint.
And if it's
pin-jointed and there's
no moments at the
nodes, then we just
get axial forces
along the members.
And even if the
nodes were fixed--
as they are in these
ceramic honeycombs--
you can show that if
it's triangulated,
even if you accounted
for any bending,
it really is a very tiny
contribution to the deformation
in the forces.
It's less than a
couple of percent.
I'll say even if
the ends are fixed--
I'll just say the bending
contributes less than 2%
to the forces in
the deformation.
If I have a triangular
cell like that,
and say I pick a
unit cell like this,
and I say that the
bulk stress produces
a load of p on the
top and p over 2
at each of the
bottom nodes there,
then the force in each member is
going to be proportional to p.
And for a given
geometry of triangle,
you can figure out exactly what
the force distribution would
be in each of the members.
But I'm going to use one of
these proportional arguments
again, just to get
a general result.
Because I don't really care
that much about the details
of the geometry.
OK.
If I have a little
set up like this,
I can say that
the overall stress
is going to be
proportional to p over lb.
And the stress in
each member is going
to be proportional to p
over l times the thickness--
or b times the thickness.
This is the overall stress.
The overall strain
is going to be
proportional to some deflection
of the triangle divided
by the length.
So if I said, say, this
length here was a length l.
And then the deflection
of each member
is going to be
proportional to p times l
over es times the cross
sectional area of the member,
and that's just b times t.
OK?
So this is the stress
on the whole thing,
the strain on the whole
thing, and relating
the delta to the p.
And then, the modulus
of the whole honeycomb
is going to go as the
stress over the strain.
So that's p over lb
divided by delta over l.
These l's here cancel.
And delta here is pl
over es bt, and so
the b's cancel and
the p's cancel.
And the modulus I get
for the honeycomb is just
some constant related to the
cell geometry times the modulus
of the solid times t over l.
And if you did an
exact calculation
for equilateral triangles, you'd
find that that constant's 1.15.
The interesting
thing to note here
is that the modulus for
these triangular honeycombs
goes as t over l, not
as t over l cubed.
For the hexagonal honeycomb,
it went as t over l cubed.
And here, because
the deformations
are axial-- not bending--
it's much stiffer.
And it's much
stiffer to have one
of these triangulated
structures.
I'll just say, here,
that the modulus goes
as t over l cubed
for the hexagonal
honeycombs due to the bending.
One of the reasons that people
are interested in those lattice
materials is that
they, too, have
moduli that go as t over l.
That basically go with
the relative density,
rather than with the
relative density cubed.
So they're much stiffer than,
say, a hexagonal honeycomb.
OK?
Are we good with the
triangulated honeycombs?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is c?
LORNA GIBSON: c's just a
constant related to the cell
geometry.
For equilateral
triangles, it's 1.15.
You could work it
out, but it just
makes the whole thing a little
more complicated to do that.
OK.
That's the in-plane behavior.
And next, I wanted to talk
about the out-of-plane behavior.
Remember, we said the hexagonal
honeycombs are orthotropic
and the orthotropic materials
have nine elastic constants.
And we've figured
out four so far.
We've figured out the four
in-plane elastic constants.
There's five out-of-plane
elastic constants
to describe the elastic
behavior completely.
And so we want to talk about
these other elastic constants.
The honeycombs are
also-- I should just
back up a little bit.
The honeycombs are used
in sandwich panels.
And when they're used
in sandwich panels--
I brought a little panel
in with carbon fiber faces
and a nomex core.
If you bend that
panel like that,
you're going to get shear
stresses in the core.
And the shear stresses
are going to be
going this way and this way
on, and that way, that way on.
And so those shear
stresses are out-of-plane.
They're in the x1,
x3, or x2, x3 planes.
And so you need the
out-of-plane properties
for the shear properties
in the sandwich panels.
Honeycombs are
also sometimes used
as energy absorption devices.
Not these rubber ones, but
imagine there was a metal one.
And when they're used for
energy absorption devices,
they're typically
loaded this way on.
Again, that's the
out-of-plane direction
and you need the
out-of-plane properties.
And for the
out-of-plane properties,
the cell walls
don't tend to bend.
Instead, they just
extend or contract.
And you get stiffer and
stronger properties.
Let me just write something
down and then we'll
start to derive some
of those properties.
The cell walls contract or
expand instead of bending,
and that gives stiffer
and stronger properties.
OK.
There's five elastic constants
in the out-of-plane directions.
We'll start with
the Young's modulus.
And if I take my
honeycomb and I load it
in the x3 direction-- just
taking this thing here and just
loading it like that-- the cell
walls just axially contract
and the stiffness just depends
on how much cell wall I've got.
So the modulus in
the three direction
is just equal to
the area fraction
times the modulus of the solid.
That's just the same
as the volume fraction,
or the relative density.
So it's quite straightforward.
The cell walls contract
or extend axially.
e3 is just es times
the relative density.
And that's just
es times t over l.
And then there's a
geometrical factor here.
h over l plus 2 over 2.
h over la plus sin
theta times cos theta.
Again, a little bit like
those triangular honeycombs.
The thing to notice here is
that in the three direction,
the modulus goes
linearly with t over l,
whereas in the
in-plane directions,
it goes with t over l cubed.
So there's a huge
anisotropy in the honeycombs
because of this difference.
Imagine a honeycomb
might be 10% dense.
t over l might be something
like a tenth-- 0.1.
So e star 3 is
going to 0.1 of es,
roughly, and in the
other direction,
it's going to be 1/1000th.
So there's a huge
anisotropy because of this.
Let me just-- square honeycombs.
This just shows looking at
the out-of-plane directions
and the different
stresses and properties
that we're going
to look at here.
The next one we're going to
look at is Poisson's ratio.
And first, we're going to look
at loading in the x3 direction.
And if we load it
in the x3 direction,
the cell wall's just strain by
whatever the Poisson's ratio
is for the solid times the
strain in the three direction
in the other two directions.
We'll say for loading in the
x3 direction, the cell wall's
strain by nu of the
solid times whatever
the strain is in the three
direction in the other two
directions.
If we load it in the x3
directions and everything
contracts by that much in the
other two directions, that just
means that the Poisson's
ratios-- nu 3 1 and nu 3 2
are going to be the same.
And they're just going to
be equal to the Poisson's
ratio of the solid.
So if each wall is going
to contract by that amount,
the whole thing's going to
contract by that amount.
And that's going to give
you that Poisson's ratio.
Let me just say, here,
also-- and remember
that I'm defining nu ij as
minus epsilon j over epsilon i.
We're loading in the
three direction here.
And then you can get the
other two Poisson's ratios
using those reciprocal
relationships.
So nu 1 3 and nu
2 3 can be found
from the reciprocal relations.
And remember,
those relationships
come from saying
that the compliance
tensor, or the stiffness
tensor, is symmetric.
We can write, for instance,
that nu 1 3 over e1
is equal to nu 3 1 over e3.
So I can write that like that.
And then I can say nu 1
3-- that is going to equal
to nu 3 1 times e1 over e3.
And we just saw that nu
3 1 was equal to nu s.
And we see, from before, the
e1 is equal to some constant.
Let me just call it c1 times
es times t over l cubed.
And e3 is going to be some
other constant times es
time t over l.
The es's are going to go.
And if t over l is
small-- even if it's say,
a 10th-- and this is
going as t over l cubed
and that's going
as t over l, then
I can say this thing
is about equal to 0.
It's going to be small.
It's not to be
exactly [INAUDIBLE] 0,
but it's going to be small
so we're going to say it's 0.
So I'll just say
for small t over l.
And then, similarly, nu 2 3
is going to be close to 0,
as well.
So there's the Poisson's ratios.
We've got the Young's
modulus, the Poisson's ratios,
and next we want to
get the Shear moduli.
And the shear moduli is
little more complicated.
The cell walls are
loaded in shear
but the neighboring cell
walls constrain them
and they produce some
non-uniform strain.
I'm talking about
shearing it this way on.
You can see on this
figure here, we're
talking about shearing it, like
tau 2 3 or tau 1 3, this way.
And so each wall
is going to shear,
but the walls are
attached to each other
so they can't just
do it independently.
They have to be
constrained by each other.
And the exact solution is
a little bit complicated.
And I'm just going to give
you an estimate of what
that modulus is.
And we're going to see that it
depends linearly on t over l,
as well.
I'll just say the cell
walls are loaded in shear.
An estimate is g star 1 3 is
equal to g of the solid times
t over l times a
geometric function.
It's cos theta over h
over l plus sin theta.
And for regular
hexagonal honeycombs,
it's 1 over root 3
times gs times t over l.
Again, just note the
linear dependence
of the modulus on t over l.
And in the book,
there's a method
using upper and
lower bounds that
gives an estimate for g 2 3.
I'm not going to go into it.
I just want you to
notice that the shear
moduli go as t over l, just
like the Young's modulus does.
And Sardar, who's sitting
in the back there,
has done even more involved
calculations and analysis
of the shear moduli of the
honeycombs in this direction.
So I'm not going to go into
all the gory details on that.
OK.
That gives us the moduli now.
So now we've got all
nine elastic moduli.
OK?
And the next thing
to do is, then,
to figure out the
compressive strength.
So we're going to look
at compression again,
and then we'll look at tension.
If we look at
compressive strengths,
again, we've got different
modes of failure.
And if I have an elastomeric
honeycomb like this one
here-- if these cell walls
were a little longer,
I might be able
to actually do it.
If you compress this
enough, you produce
buckling in the cell walls.
And this is a schematic of
this buckling pattern here.
And you can see there's
a diamond pattern where
it alternates up and down
in the different cell walls.
We're going to do some
approximate calculations,
but you can see the idea
of how the material behaves
in this direction, just from
these approximate calculations.
OK.
Say we have our
honeycomb like this,
and here's the
prism axis this way.
And now, we're
going to load it up
with some stress in
the three direction.
I'm going to call this sigma
star elastic 3 when it buckles.
And what we're going to do is
just look at a single plate.
And look at the
buckling of a plate.
We're going to analyze it
just looking at a single plate
and then adding up how many
plates we have per unit cell.
It's actually more
complicated than this
because, obviously, the
plates are attached together
and there's some constraint
by attaching the plates.
But we're not going
to worry about that.
If you have a
column-- just a, say,
circular cross-section
column-- and you
apply a compressive load to it,
it buckles at the Euler load.
And similarly, there's
an Euler load for plates.
And that equation
is usually written
as a p critical is equal to
some end constraint factor.
For plates, it's usually
called k instead of n.
So this is an end
constraint factor.
It depends on the
modulus of the plate.
It goes as t cubed.
Then, there's a factor of 1
minus mu of the solid squared
and the length of the plate.
Say this plate here--
actually the width
of the plate there is h
and the length here is b.
And this thickness
here is t like that.
Here, k is an end
constraint factor.
And it's going to depend on the
stiffness of the adjacent cell
walls.
If I had a honeycomb, and
say it was-- these walls
here-- the adjacent
walls-- were thicker,
then you can imagine those
thicker walls-- it'd be harder
to get them to deform.
And the end constraint
for the plate
is going to depend on
those thicker walls.
So that the end
constraint, k, depends
on these-- say I'm looking
at this wall here of width h
here, then how stiff
these other two walls
are is going to affect
that end constraint factor.
What we're going to do is just
do something very approximate.
We're going to say if these
vertical edges here-- if this
edge here and that one there--
if they were simply supported--
if they're just pinned
to the next column,
the next member--
then k has some value.
And if they're fixed,
it has some other value.
And we're going to pick
a value in between.
So we're going to do
something very approximate.
I'll say if those
vertical edges are simply
supported-- that means
they're free to rotate-- then
k is equal to 2.0.
And this is if b is bigger
than three times the length.
So this is h here,
or we could say l.
Either way.
It's really the--
it's the length when
we look at the
honeycomb this way on,
but it's the width in
that picture there.
And if the vertical edges
are clamped, or fixed,
then k is equal to 6.2.
These are values you can look
up in tables of plate buckling.
And we're just going
to approximate it
by saying k is equal to 4.
We're just picking a value
that's in between those two.
And then, the p
total is going to be
the sum of the p
criticals for the columns
that make up a unit cell.
For the unit cell, I
have one wall of length h
and two of length l.
And if you just
take that total load
and divide by the
area of the cell,
you get that this compressive
strength for elastic buckling
is approximately equal
to es over 1 minus nu
s squared times t over l cubed.
And then there's a
geometrical factor here.
And if you had regular
hexagonal cells,
this buckling stress works
out to 5.2 times es times
t over l cubed.
If you remember, for the
loading in the two direction--
in the in-plane direction--
it has the same form.
And goes as es times t over l
cubed, but it's much smaller.
This number here
was, I think, 0.2.
It was much smaller.
So it has the same form,
but it's a lot bigger.
OK?
Are we good with that?
The idea is we just use
the standard equations
for plate buckling.
We make some estimate of what
that end constraint factor is.
And we just have an
approximate calculation here.
OK.
That's the elastic buckling.
If I had a metal
honeycomb, then it
might not fail by elastic
buckling like that.
Instead, we'd
probably get yielding.
If it was dense
enough, we could just
get axial yielding that--
if you just loaded it,
you'd have axial forces.
And at some point, you'd
reach the yield stress.
And so you can get failure
by just uniaxial yield.
That's one option.
And if you get
that, then it just
depends on how much
solid you've got again.
So it's just the yield
strength of the solid times
the relative density.
But usually, the honeycomb
is thinner walled than that.
And usually, you get plastic
buckling proceeding that.
In plastic buckling,
you can think of it
as-- say if you have a
tube-- this is just shown
for an individual tube here.
You can see how
the tube folds up.
And you can get that same kind
of thing with the honeycomb.
Here's a single tube.
It's been loaded along the
prism axis of the tube.
And you can see,
you get these folds,
and the more you load it, the
more number of folds you get.
And the more the
folds concertina up.
To do an exact analysis
for the honeycombs,
you would have to take into
account not just one tube,
but the constraint of the
neighboring tubes again.
And again, that gets to be
a complicated, messy thing.
So again, we're going to do
a more approximate thing.
What we're going to do is
just say that we have members
that are folding up like that.
So the same geometry.
But we're just going to
look at a single cell wall
and see what the
single cell wall does.
And someone else has done
the more exact calculation.
We'll just compare our
approximate calculation
to the exact one.
OK.
We're going to consider an
approximate calculation.
What we're going do is look
at our isolated cell wall.
And if you look at
the figure here,
the wall is going to
be vertical, initially.
And as we load it, eventually
it's going to buckle
and we're going to form
one of those plastic hinges
in the middle here.
And then, the
thing is then going
to rotate about that plastic
hinge and just fold up.
So at the bottom here,
it's completely folded up.
OK?
And we're going to do a
little work calculations.
We're going to look at
the internal work done
and we're going to look
at the external work done.
The external work
is just going to be
this load p times
that deflection delta
that the p moves through.
And if we say this is
half of a wavelength--
if you think of this thing going
through multiple wavelengths,
just consider when it
folds up like that,
that's a half of a wavelength.
It would go two of those
to get a full wavelength.
That's lambda over 2.
And so to go from this stage
to that stage over here,
the external work done is
going to be approximately p
times lambda over 2.
Say that it's thin and that 2t
is small compared to lambda.
So it's going to be about
p times lambda over 2.
And then, we're also going
to look at the work done
by the plastic moment.
And when we form the
plastic hinge here,
there's a plastic moment.
And that moment is going to
rotate through an angle of pi.
So we start out straight here,
we end up folded up like that,
and we've gone from
straight to that.
We had to go through 180
degrees to get there.
So it goes through
an angle of pi.
And if you have a moment
going through a rotation,
the work done is the
moment times the rotation.
We're going to equate
those two works done.
We're going to look at the
rotation of the cell wall
by an angle of pi at
the plastic hinge.
Our plastic moment-- it's
going to be the yield
strength of the
solid again times t
squared over 4,
the same as when we
were talking about the
plastic moment before
for the other loading direction.
But now, instead of
multiplying this times b,
we're multiplying
it times 2l plus h.
That's the length
of the cell wall
that's associated with one cell.
And now, it's not
b because now we've
turned the thing
the other way on.
We're loading it
And this plastic
hinge-- if I think
of-- if this was b before.
And now that b is l plus
2h-- or 2l plus h, rather.
That's the dimension of the--
let me draw a little hexagon so
maybe you can see.
OK.
Now we're forming a plastic
hinge halfway down the board.
Imagine that this has some
length b that way and we're
halfway down the board.
And now, the plastic hinge
has to form all the way
around these members
here for one cell.
Or you could think about it
as this guy plus these guys
is one cell.
You can think about the
unit cell different ways,
but it's one h plus two l's.
OK?
Are we OK with that?
OK.
Then the internal plastic
work is that plastic moment
times the rotation
pho-- or pi, rather.
Sorry.
Are we OK with this?
That the work done
is m times our angle?
Imagine-- let me get rid
of my honeycomb here.
Imagine you have a
point here and you
have some force over here.
Let's call that f.
And say, the force is
at distance r from f.
And say that it moves
through some distance.
The moment here
would be r times f.
And if that rotates,
say, through some angle--
let's call it alpha--
and here is f here, then
this distance here that
the force moves through
is just r times alpha.
So the work done is going
to be r times alpha times f,
or just the moment times alpha.
OK?
So that's all that we're doing.
OK.
That's the internal
plastic work.
And now we have to look
at the external work done.
And that's equal to p
times lambda over 2.
Here, lambda is the half
wavelength of the buckling.
I'm going to say for these
tubular kinds of things,
it's in the order of l.
So if you look at that
last slide here-- oops.
Rats.
How'd that happen?
Let me scoot back down here.
There.
If we look at that guy
again, the magnitude
of the buckling wavelength
is on the order of l.
And here, below p, can
be related to the stress
in the three direction.
We'll just multiply it times
the area of the unit cell.
And so if I equate the internal
work and the external work,
I can say p times
lambda over 2 is
equal to pi times
my plastic moment.
And then, for p, I can
write sigma 3 h plus l sin
theta times 2l cos theta.
And then, lambda is l
divided by 2 is equal to pi.
And then I've got my
plastic moment over there.
And then if I solve for sigma 3,
that's my compressor strength.
I've got pi by 4, the strength
of the solid, sigma ys, times
t over l squared.
Then h over l plus 2 divided by
h over l plus sin theta times
cos theta.
And for the regular
hexagons, this
works out to about 2 sigma
ys times to over l squared.
And the exact calculation
for regular honeycombs
is equal to 5.6 times
sigma ys times t over l
to the 5/3 power.
This power here-- 5/3--
is a little less than 2.
And that's because the
additional constraint
of the neighboring cell walls.
But the main thing
we're interested in,
in these sorts of calculations,
is the power dependence
on the density and this
simple calculation.
Obviously, it's not exact,
but it gets you close.
OK.
I'm just going to wait for
people to catch up a little.
OK.
The next property
I'm going to look at
is out-of-plane
brittle fractures.
Say we loaded in tension, and if
we had no cracks in the walls,
we'd just see uniaxial tension
and the strength would just
be the strength of the solid
times the relative density
times the amount of solid.
We'll just say if defect free,
the walls see uniaxial tension.
And then the fracture stress
in the three direction
is just equal to the relative
density times the fracture
strength of the solid.
If the cell walls are cracked,
and if the crack length
is very much bigger
than the cell length,
then the crack
propagates normal to x3.
Then we can say the toughness
gc-- or the critical strain
energy release rate-- is
just equal to the volume
fraction of solid
times gc for the solid.
And then the fracture
toughness, k1c,
is equal to the square root of
the Young's modulus times gc.
And that's just equal
to the relative density
times the modulus of the solid.
And then the relative
density times the toughness
of the solid.
So it's just equal to
the relative density
times the fracture
toughness of the solid.
It's just straightforward there.
Then we've got one last
out-of-plane property.
And that's brittle
crushing and compression.
And if we have some compressive
strength of the cell wall--
say I call it cs-- then it's
just the relative density
times that strength.
And for brittle materials,
that crushing strength
is typically around 12 times the
modulus of rupture, or fracture
strength.
We could say that's
about equal to 12
times the relative density times
sigma fs, a fracture strength.
OK.
That's the modeling
of the honeycombs.
I know there's been a lot of
equations and derivations,
but that's the basis
of a lot of the things
we're going to do in
the rest of the course.
The modeling we're going to do
on the foams is based on this
and the mathematics
is just easier
because we're going to use
these dimensional arguments.
We're not going
to figure out all
these geometrical parameters.
Before we get to
the foams, I wanted
to talk a little bit about
honeycombs in nature.
And we've only got a
couple minutes left,
so I won't really get that far.
But I wanted to talk a little
bit about honeycomb materials
in nature.
And the two examples
we're going to talk about
are wood and cork.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about the structure of wood
next time.
Then, we'll see how we can apply
these models to understanding
how wood behaves.
And we'll see how you
can use these models
to predict the density
dependence of wood properties
and also the anisotropy
in wood properties.
And I guess we'll probably,
maybe, start it Wednesday
next week.
We'll talk about cork, as well.
Those of you who
took 3032 know that I
like cork because of Robert
Hooke and his drawing of cork.
And I made a new video
that I'm going to show you.
Remember in 3032, I
showed you the video
from the Bodleian Library,
where they had the first edition
of Hooke's Micrographia.
Well, it turns out Harvard
has a first edition.
Harvard has three
first editions.
Yeah.
Exactly.
MIT has zero first editions.
Gee, why does that surprise me?
And I have a friend who's
a librarian at Harvard
and she arranged for
me to go and make
a little video with the first
edition of Micrographia.
So I can-- I don't if
we'll play the whole thing,
but I'll show you the
first little bit of it.
And you can watch
it at your leisure.
And Sardar came.
You came and saw it with me.
You came and saw the first
edition with me, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
LORNA GIBSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's very beautiful and you'll
see some of the nice drawings.
And I talk about the
cellular structure
of some of the drawings.
So we'll talk about
wood and cork next time.
But I think I'm going to
stop there because that seems
like enough equations for now.